[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an australian science fiction
film called 2067.
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the premise of the movie is set in 2067
when the world has been destroyed beyond
rehabilitation because of climate change
all plant life has been extinct with a
lack of plant life the amount of oxygen
in the air has decreased exponentially
people have to buy artificial oxygen to
survive
ninety-nine percent of the world has
gone dark
people suffocate to death
in such conditions only one city in
australia has survived and it is all
thanks to a company called the chrono
corp corporation that manufactures
synthetic oxygen however artificial
oxygen causes a fatal disease called the
sickness over time
humankind has mere years before it goes
fully extinct
ethan white is a resident of the
australian city he and his friend jude
work as mechanics in the chronicler
corporation
the corporation is also working day and
night to find a cure for the sickness
and a way to save the world
ethan's wife xanthe also has the
sickness
ethan works hard day and night to earn
and buy her better oxygen one day as
ethan and jude work in the tunnel the
chronic orb cto of particle research
regina jackson summons them to her
office
there she introduces herself to the two
and tells them that humanity is going to
die in a few years if the conditions do
not change
she then reveals that ethan is the only
one who can help everyone and save
humanity ethan is confused and doesn't
believe her but regina insists he visit
their lab
the lab has huge machinery the lab
doctor named billy mitchell introduces
himself to ethan and looks at ethan's
wrist device for a second they then
explained to him that ethan's father dr
richard white started this project 20
years ago the machine that stands in
front of them is a time machine called
the chronicle in the first ever
experiment done with the machine they
had to send radio waves into it to check
what was on the other side
they found out through it that 407 years
later in 2474
the earth would have enough vegetation
to maintain enough oxygen in the air and
sustain human life
the people come to believe that if
humanity still exists several hundred
years later it is likely that they have
found solutions to all the problems
plaguing their reality
however a strange activity baffled the
scientists there the waves they sent had
come back reformed when they decoded it
they found out that someone from the
future had sent them the message saying
send ethan white
so now regina and the whole team want to
send ethan into the future for him to
bring back the cure ethan is beyond
surprised
he doesn't believe them and thinks that
regina is just bluffing moreover he
doesn't want to leave his sick wife and
go into the future
so he declines to help
later ethan and jude are at a diner
where they buy crisp oxygen
jude tries to persuade ethan to go
through with the plan and help save
humanity however ethan laughs at him
saying that he doesn't want to be like
his father
ethan hates his father for never being
there for him twenty years ago his
father left home and went missing while
his mother was killed when he was a kid
since then he has been brought up by
jude who he regards as his older brother
as well as best friend he blames his
father for leaving his mother to
complete the project and doesn't want to
follow in his path and leave his sick
wife however jude manages to persuade
him saying that the only way he can save
his wife is by finding a cure ethan
reminisces of his eighth birthday when
his father has bought him a strange box
as a gift as he puts his hands inside
the box a device latches onto his wrist
making him bleed
richard had placed a permanent hand
device on his son
it has been many years but ethan doesn't
know its use yet
later at home ethan tells xanthe
everything that happened during the day
and she too insists him to go
the following morning ethan scribes i
will find my way back to you on a metal
flower and leaves it besides anthony he
then goes to regina's office again and
tells her that if he can find only one
cure they will have to give it first to
xanthe regina accepts and takes him to
the lab again
dr mitchell shows him the suit that he
has to wear before getting into the
machine
as they begin to explain the mission to
him ethan realizes that they do not have
a plan
they have no clue what he will see or
who he will meet at the other end
however after they put him in the suit
they give him an ai device called the
archie archie will show the lab ethan's
vitals at all times it will also help to
navigate his location
then they finally throw him into the
machine
inside ethan moves at high speed through
time he falls from the sky and lands in
an unknown jungle
the friction from the air causes his
suit to catch fire so he quickly gets
out of it then he looks around and is
astounded by the beauty of nature he
finds that the world has completely
changed the trees and the natural oxygen
are back
he walks in the direction archie directs
him and sees a bunker door of some sort
but what catches his eyes is a skeleton
that lies right in front of the door
its skull has a bullet hole in it
furthermore he looks at the name tag on
it and is horrified to see his own name
the skeleton is ethan's ethan also finds
the skeletons archie and plays the last
recording on it he hears a man say that
this is the only way and shoots ethan
just then the device's power goes off he
is horrified believing that this is the
fate that awaits him then he notices the
skeleton's wrist device
it is identical to ethan's except the
light glows green in the skeleton's
device but ethan's has been red his
whole life that night he lights a fire
and eats wild berries
it turns out that the berries were
poisonous ethan vomits and starts to go
unconscious ethan wakes up after a while
and is surprised to see jude in front of
him as it turns out the lab saw ethan's
vitals dropping and assumed he was
having a reaction to poison
so they quickly sent jude to the future
with the cure to save him
some time later ethan and jude find that
his skeleton remains there which means
his fate hasn't changed they then use
archie to find another door
some device scans ethan's eye and grants
them access
when they go in a monitor welcomes him
it asks him for a dna sample
when he accepts it his wrist device
begins to work making him bleed
after the blood test it goes green
the lights to the room turn on and they
realize that they are in chrono corpse
lab 407 years later the time machine is
in front of them too
jude gets excited because now they have
the means to go back to the past but
ethan doesn't think so saying they
haven't changed anything and he will end
up dead just like the dead ethan
ethan checks the system log and finds a
holographic recording made by his father
who explains that the time machine was
originally designed to collect the
oxygen data in the future planet and
then transmit it back to the past
however when his father first started
the time machine he received a message
asking him to send his son to the future
despite his misgivings he chose to do so
and made a dna verification here for
ethan
soon ethan and jude realized that the
time machine won't be able to take them
back because its battery has almost
depleted after 407 years what's worse is
that the activation of the lab triggers
a malfunction in its nuclear power core
threatening to unleash a nuclear
explosion in just four hours
this means they have to find a way to
fix the time machine and travel back
before the explosion
running out of time they have to act
quickly
outside they are surprised to find a
ruined city covered with green plants
but inhabited with no humans showing
that earth starts to recover itself
after human extinction
human skeletons are scattered everywhere
ethan gets to his wife's house only to
find her bones making him fall into
despair
jude tries to persuade him to go back to
the past as the cure against the
sickness doesn't seem to exist even in
the future world however jude's words
make ethan suspicious he then turns on
the rusty archie to play the recording
once again from which he recognizes
jude's voice and it seems jude is
exactly the one who shot him
jude raises his gun at ethan strongly
denying that he would shoot ethan ethan
finally decides to complete the mission
first so with joint efforts they managed
to repair the power core and then return
to the lab now the chronicle system
works and they should be able to return
to the past they just need to wait 37
minutes till portal launch
once the countdown reaches zero the
portal will tether to 2067 for
approximately 30 seconds
however ethan still finds his body
remains behind a door at the same
location which implies that they haven't
made any changes to the future
in order to figure out the truth ethan
pulls out the battery of his current
archie and puts it onto the rusty one in
that way he gets access to another video
in which ethan is assured that his
future self will be killed by jude jude
then confesses that there is no hope of
changing the future and he is trying to
protect ethan
finding it hard to believe ethan locks
his brother up in a room then plays back
his father's holographic log from the
day he died he soon discovers a
conversation between the chronocorps cto
regina jackson and his father it's shown
that ethan's father wanted to use the
time machine to save all mankind by
finding the cure but the cto only
intended to use the machine to flee from
the dying time with some chosen few
however whichever plan they choose
someone must travel into the future and
turn on the time machine to safely send
living matter through time it requires
an operational link from both sides
in order to stop the cto with her plan
his father locks the time machine and
sets ethan's dna as the verification key
in anger at what ethan's father just did
the cto killed him immediately
she then orders jude to kill ethan's
mother and be a guardian to him so one
day they can use ethan's wristband to
get access to the future
ethan is beyond surprised the man he
thought of as his brother turned out to
be the one who killed his mother and is
about to kill him too
he also realizes that he has
misunderstood his father who didn't
deliberately abandon the family
knowing that regina wants to bring a
chosen few into the future ethan tries
to shut the time machine down but jude
rushes to stop ethan and reveals that
he's tasked here by the cto to ensure
that ethan is sent in time to repair the
power failure once ethan activates the
time machine he should kill ethan
however jude has formed close emotional
relations with ethan over the years
seeing his brother-like friend in that
state because of him he is guilt-ridden
so instead of shooting ethan he shoots
himself dead
in rage and regret ethan is determined
to fulfill his father's dying wish which
is to find the cure and save the dying
humans
he looks into the monitor and finds the
very first message written by his father
he deduces that the message sent ethan
white was sent by himself
hence he codes in the message again and
sends it into the past along with many
other things meanwhile in the laboratory
of the year 2067 the cto with a group of
privileged chosen people are waiting
anxiously for the time machine to be
activated
to their shock however the time machine
sends back hundreds of extinct plants
along with a copy of the recorded murder
of ethan's father soon after the time
machine is destroyed by ethan resulting
in the collapse of the cto's plan
in the end the cto is arrested due to
the murder
the plants sent back to 2067 are
cultivated to revitalize the planet
ethan's wife also receives a flower sent
from him and understands his choice
while ethan has to stay in the future
world alone he buries jude and forgives
him a butterfly catches his attention
and leads him again to the same entrance
where ethan is happy to notice that the
corpse of his future self is gone
he rushes to take a look at the world
outside and feels relieved to see a
futuristic eco-friendly city in contrast
to the deserted one from earlier his
decision had changed the future of
mankind
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching